hi my name is jim clewine and i'm a
technical fellow in microsoft 365
responsible for the architecture of the
office cloud services
thank you for attending the sessions for
the cloud intelligence and ai operations
track
after over a decade of running one of
the world's great hyper scale services i
can tell you from firsthand experience
that one of the biggest threats to the
safe operation of any truly hyper scale
service is the intersection of scale
complexity and delays in human response
automating operation of those services
can help deliver high availability and
great user experience because automation
is generally faster than human reaction
time
yet the scale and complexity of those
services makes it impractical to deliver
that automation using traditional
approaches
today's sessions have focused heavily on
evolving past traditional approaches to
make these services truly self-operating
through broad ai based operations and
automation
as real-world services like microsoft
365 scale and become more complex
as the world depends on them more which
it inevitably must
the research presented in this track
will become increasingly foundational to
the industry
microsoft is already using some of this
research in the operation of our clouds
and where we've been able to use it it's
been transformational that's not a word
i use easily transformational but it's
true admittedly
we've implemented automation mostly in
post-deployment operations i'm very
interested in watching this technology
move to earlier stages in the services
life cycle
in the fullness of time i hope to see it
even in the design and architecture
phases of these services
the need to help accommodate scale and
complexity at the speed of automation
with ai will eventually extend across
all phases of designing building and
operating services
i'm very excited that microsoft is
leading in this research but i'm even
more excited
that we're partnering with others like
you to advance the state of the art to
openly publish it and to democratize it
this technology is not a secret sauce we
want to keep to ourselves it's something
we want available to anyone in the
industry
i'd urge you to work with us in this
area or just build on what we do and
share it with others
thank you again for your time and we
hope to see you at another microsoft
research event soon